okay what tickle Liberty hope you'll
drink [ __ ] you and mom thank you so
actually had this really cool idea I
heard the Middleton Place is going to be
launching a bee farm think that it might
be a really good idea that we reach out
maybe talk about a collaboration if
that's a beautiful spot I think they're
developing something that's of really
good quality leading up to the bee farm
for instance and check out the different
bees that they have and what kinds of
tastes at the evoke whenever the beasts
produced the honey you know like those
are the kinds of things that we want to
be thinking about maybe we didn't be
helpful if we just go out there first I
think just getting out there seeing the
process to kind of understand a little
more just immersing ourselves what kind
of notes or flavors can we expect on
this patch of honey based on the plant
walk around here mostly Palmetto also to
blow and tulip tree blackberry and then
a bunch of assertive live flowers
they're getting throughout the year
maybe even grab some samples we're
thinking about doing a collaboration
later this year I could be good to maybe
take those back research a little bit
taste a little bit and kind of get some
creative ideas phone yeah definitely I
think Charleston for us has been
somewhat of a blank canvas to come in
here and to improve on things but I
think also just work with the community
here that's already making this place a
great place and I think you know what we
want to do is is continue to challenge
ourselves to to really be better people
but you better people for the community
you had to help it engage I think a
little more of that contemporary culture